90 Day Fiance we're back Ken oh God and
wait we got a good one we got Angela and
Michael the love of the century cream of
the crop they're Nigerian prince meets
the Disney princess from America
let's check it out I'm Angela I'm from
Hazlehurst Georgia I'm 52 but I tell
everybody I'm 50.
what does that mean we are 50 you don't
look 50 you look we're like 52s
[Applause]
she starts sweating like oh God how'd
they know they must have counted my
wrinkles I feel like if someone says
that that's a that's a red herring she's
like 62. she says it right now
yeah yeah anyway she's about to meet the
love of her life baby
one day a message pops up
[Music]
a guy named Michael you look pretty
today good morning that means he's been
stalking her right hmm pretty pretty
today compared to all these other days
I've been watching you I do you know who
he was but his profile picture looked
cute
oh
yeah boy looking cute right now looking
cute as hell
he's from Nigeria and he's 30 years old
all right so that's the gist of it let's
see the meet up my hands are drilling
with water
um
sorry but what is her T-shirt be your
selfie
okay
don't drop your bags
what is that audience is getting hyped
up
[Music]
they're not short oh yeah why would you
go there
why would you say that what would you do
she was short thank God you're not sure
that would have been awkward
if Marissa said that to me when I met
her I'd be like I'm flying back
Michael I couldn't hold myself back you
know I just had to run to him because
that's my sex and Nigerian baby
[Music]
you think he said that he's a Nigerian
prince like the way he looked when she's
like yeah I'm here and he's just like no
no responses I was the best no you never
heard of the Nigerian friends scam oh
the scam to get like oh people's money
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm a Nigerian
prince give me all your money because uh
but then she showed up and he's like ah
dang it it just came from the heart and
that's it and
see wiping his lips after kissing her
she's like
yeah
that was gross oh you were
filming oh no not he's gonna wipe again
now
God dang it
I just wonder what happened with the
bags
you got cut off she is so shallow I
can't believe it she doesn't get better
he only gets worse
that's right it's kind of bigger than uh
there it is she looks older than the
pictures
he got catfished
her stature looks bigger that's the
nicest way you can say that you're not
sure
um you're old and you're stature
so he got catfished all right I'm happy
I'm a whim
I can tell from your emotions you look
overwhelmed if I feel he's not loving me
the way I think he's loving me is off
that quick
that's
a nice way to build a relationship
so this is our before Mary had another
daughter named Mariah
is that her and so why would the
grandmother be back because Angie again
thinks that she looks mad mother of this
child either
foreign
I do not have 22 kids the DNA test will
prove it
oh my God
can y'all catch her up I'm telling
myself I like the chair between them the
only thing stopping this brawl happening
how was that guy in that house okay so
she's a drama queen we know that at
least we need the YouTube equivalent of
this show oh
okay you copied me
boy look at that
you make the same stupid react face in
every video I was the one that started
with a red background on the thumbnail
here stop there
to my game no one else can react to it
you're just a copy again come up with a
real material B they have like gamer
chairs they throw to like dicks racers
I've had love before but
when you're appreciated in love it's
different I think Michael appreciates me
it's a different feeling
great it's pretty sad early
Angela is different from what I was
expecting she's kind of loud I'll try
and give a sign just to bring a voice
down a little if she's like too dramatic
he's already done with her yeah good
luck with that Michael you know
I mean she's so mature I mean she's fun
loving yeah
oh my God
they're like little kids I love it she
has so much energy like man like a man I
got some surprises for you oh really
yeah
yeah what do you think the surprise
wait wait you gotta spread that Trump
religion that's the only way huh
all right this is a time I'm happy to
not go back to you know what I mean
John this is all Trump merge yeah this
is gonna spread the cult to Trump as
soon as she gets here
Welcome to My Country by the way have
you heard of the one true Lord and
Savior Trump like something like
I don't know what they call it what it
is oh my God I love the old pocket I
think you explained it I love it I'm
gonna Trump you up
no now you're hot now
yeah
I mean she's so joyous she's happy I
should be able to go puta I mean cope
for the next couple of weeks I should be
I should I think I think I can handle it
I think I can do this deep breaths I got
all the Donald Trump merch a little
nervous wouldn't you be nervous me naked
with someone you love and you never
touched but I ain't even with a man in a
year he's in trouble
Michael
[Music]
come on
I don't know this is I don't need to see
this man because he's very young I'm
very uncomfortable
I think Michael's a little bit more shy
and reserved than me hello um but yeah
there's like three cameramen in the room
of course he's a little shot
I know Michael
nice you light it up
[Applause]
oh what's happening
[Music]
what's happening
we briefly stopped in the no parking
Zone and these tow truck guys come out
of nowhere and put iron spikes in
Michael's tires so they can tow our car
wow
[Music]
we're like Cowboys here in Nigeria what
the hell
get away from my car to be honest I I
would love to have her on my side in the
fight like yeah it was something like
this happens yeah
throw cigarettes down
[Music]
your service agreed to release his car
oh good
whoa the footage
it's so dramatic
fully set of people
are you cut Oh no you're good I can't
believe Angela is in Nigeria for a few
minutes
great if you guys back though all right
they're checking for wedding venues
they're expensive in Nigeria oh
oh yeah you know things happened
it told you bro when you smoke that many
packs of cigarettes a day you know hey
yeah she looks like she's aging every
clip so I'm Taking Angela to see a venue
so we can start planning a wedding
celebration
it looks like static I can't wait I'm
talking to my mom the truth about how
difficult it is to have a baby
her kids are like grown and like you
know done she's done having kids but he
wants one real bad yeah I ain't
happening my dude Michael okay stop
stop
can you stop American goes on a drive
it said cake
no cake
don't worry about my kid
hahaha
Event Hall
it's big yes definitely big we have the
gold the diamond and the silver nice
how much is that that's 550. 550 000 is
what in American money it does uh about
the wall I'm asking him not up to 2 000.
that's just the silver yes
when he tells me the prize I
that seems like a lot no it's a wedding
venue you know that's you just put
wedding on the front of it and the price
goes up yeah it's a grand for yeah
I'd probably pay way more but uh for
that no two grand now after Angela's
last trip
Angela and my friends you don't get
along
Angela calls my friends the ghost boss
the goofballs damn yeah making fun of me
and like they don't support my
my relationship
what's the difference
20 years
come on Mike that's too much
like bro I've never seen such thing in
my life she's just like a grandma oh
they're saying it all
she talks
yeah I'm a bit concerned about your
your life
yeah I think it's kind of fair to be
concerned yeah 20 years listen so tell
us your mind this is calm down it's kind
of down
if you guys are my friends as you said
at least you support me
support me give me
Angela before
really um I saw her on the show
she put a drink on Aid oh man
why bro we should do that
he's like give me some advice dude we
have we ever give any advice
how can she do that how could she that's
good eyes
you're making me feel as if
I'm not serious with her
okay
they call it trashy
it's like bro
why would you say she's Josh
I got a Will Smith slap coming up
then they got so defensive about it
because he knew it's true
what are you doing here I come to get
away from me that's not gonna work this
time come on he got you a cage
he's sorry
that doesn't work this time
she must be real man
whatever I did I don't think I deserved
that
I feel so embarrassed I mean
I'm really starting to think things I've
done here I mean
maybe it it may be it I'm starting to
pick up some signals some smart sort of
hints I don't know if it's just
I don't know what that is starting to
realize maybe I shouldn't be in this
relationship I'm not entirely sure
though before I proceed I would like to
inform you what the Lord does not permit
any one of you to have another marriage
he or she has committed an offense
called they got me which is punishable
under Nigeria she definitely has big on
me
she has been married before like five
years in prison she's like bro what
excuse me
no option of fine please face each other
available
thank you thank you Angela I like the
purpose yeah it was good to be my lovely
wife
are you emotional
forsaking all other women forsaking all
other women
amen candy and listen to me Michael to
be my loveful husband to be my loved
ones so love and to obey
who
[Music]
[Laughter]
just say it woman yeah
wiggling his legs he's like come on
[Music]
to loving
oh man
[Music]
I love this meme flag they just put like
the meme fun on top of it they intact
yeah the impact that's my favorite one
yeah
hey man let's go now
[Music]
beautiful it's beautiful it's beautiful
so it's so my God it brings a tear to my
eye oh I'm crying right now oh
are you at all interested in how it ends
up in the end oh okay hey you know the
you know the Spiel yeah you check out
that clip I sent you she lost a ton of
weight every time I see her she looks
completely different she lost so much
weight and this is like the tell-all
like at the end of the season they like
all sit down and like have a big a big
talk about everything
come on mouth
what happened to love and Obey no she
just stealing your words I just went
straight out huh
this is what he does when she's on the
phone
didn't your brother tell you to tell her
to stay out of here
I mean it's unfortunate yeah
it's rough she's doing her best I have
to talk
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's nothing stop
again
thank the Lord
oh my oh
uh mom is a beautiful thing Ken oh it's
a beautiful thing
[Music]
Michael and Angela what a story we're
gonna we're gonna have to wrap it up
there but thanks for showing us and uh
joining me today Ken check out Ken's
Channel everyone you're the king of 90
day you got a ton of videos so yeah
check them out if you want more of that
I got you don't you worry let me know if
you want me to do more of these as well
that's super fun so yeah and all that
I'll see you in the next one bye bye